arafa Ahmed is a school teacher who
comes to this Market in Northern umur
man to buy her basic needs it's one of
the few in the capital that remains open
since we're broke out in mid April she
says the conflict between Sudan's Army
and the country's paramilitary rapid
support forces has meant she's had
little money to buy what she needs to
survive we've only earned this month
before that there was no earning every
sudin has reduced what they buy because
there is no source of income all the
government facilities are not
functioning so there is no ability to
purchase because there is no income
there's no consumption I'm lucky to have
a son who works abroad but things are
still tough prices in the market have
increased since the War Began because of
rising fuel costs and Traders having to
import what was once locally produced
after many factories were destroyed in
the conflict like
the market is a bit slow but we're
managing some people come and when they
find the thing they want it's expensive
and they choose what is cheaper instead
because they can afford it but not all
those in Kum have access to basic Goods
while goods are available in some
markets in other parts of the capital
finding basic Commodities is challenging
that's because the fighting is
preventing Traders from being able to
move their goods leading to shortages in
many areas in Harum and other cities in
Sudan and raising prices when many have
no source of
income at least 1 million people worked
in the public sector prior to the war
and millions of others relied on day
jobs to be able to feed their families
but all that has been disrupted the
conflict has now displaced more than 5
million people and the number of people
needing humanitarian assistance to
survive has risen from 15 million to 20
million that's near nearly half of
Sudan's population and getting Aid to
those in need is challenging without
having safe passages and without
providing protection to the humanitarian
workers it's impossible for wfp to reach
out to those people who are currently
hungry who sometimes goes to bed on an
empty stomach ARA says she knows she's
lucky to be able to access and afford
her needs but she worries that she may
not be able to do so if the fighting
continues
hia Morgan Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer